the only junk DNA is in my colleagues
brains today we're featuring Craig
Venter a world-renowned biotechnologist
known for his groundbreaking
contributions to genomics he had a
pivotal role in leading the first draft
sequence of the human genome and
assembling the pioneering team that
achieved the transfection of a cell with
a synthetic chromosome cells are very
Dynamic changing second to second but
one thing is fundamental to all life and
that's the genetic code later in life he
and his research team created the
world's first synthetic organism from
scratch demonstrating the potential of
synthetic biology to engineer life at
the molecular level taking those Gene
Pathways putting them in synthetic
organisms will be able to create whole
new chemical libraries Craig's a leading
figure he's hilarious unfettered
Unshackled and unafraid you'll hear all
of that in this episode and find out why
he was among Time magazine's 100 most
influential people in the world not once
but twice maybe on another planet where
life already exists so without further
Ado we welcome a lively episode of the
into the impossible podcast my friend
Craig ventor Live recorded at UCSD this
past fall welcome everybody to what
promises to be an exciting and Lively
emphasis on lively episode of the into
the impossible podcast with none other
than Craig Venter of many different
fames but we're going to talk about a
couple of them in particular including
mapping the human genome Craig is local
here in La Hoya he has his Institute
named after him down the down the road
from our campus and he's graciously
agreed to spend some time with me I'm
going to run out of time before I run
out of questions Craig thank you so much
for visiting oh my pleasure to be here
and you're a proud alumni son of San
Diego UCSD and we're going to talk a
little bit about how the campus has
changed a little bit but sitting in that
chair a couple months back was uh Kim
Stanley Robinson who also goes by his
middle name only as Stan I don't know
what it is with you famous super famous
brilliant uh creative types So today
we're going to talk about a variety of
subjects including your recent book The
Voyage of sorcerer 2 we're going to talk
about what happened to you on sorcerer
one which is
foreshadowing but first we're going to
start with a very simple easy question
Craig and that is the one posed by irn
Schrodinger in the 50s in a monograph a
very slim monograph and that question
was what is
life it's a book I recommend that every
scientist read at least once I've read
it a few times few years back I was
asked to give uh the only time somebody
was asked to give the schinger lecture
other than schinger in the same uh Hall
under the same circumstance it was it
was really an amazing
experience and because we've designed
the first living cell uh that didn't
happen in nature people assume that I
can answer that question but he tried to
Define it in physical terms and uh you
know thought about things about the
genetic code long before Watson and
Crick and while everybody was sure that
it was proteins you know he said it
could be as simple as Morris
code and I was talking to Francis Crick
about that he goes well that was obvious
to everybody he was very dismissive of
you know that was hardly a unique notion
other than from protein chemist who uh
still refused to give Avery the Nobel
Prize for proving that DNA was the
genetic material cells are are very
Dynamic changing second to second but
one thing is fundamental to all life and
that's the genetic code if you take the
genetic code out of any cell any species
the cell dies very rapidly the species
dies that's why we're so susceptible to
radiation poisoning it basically blows
apart uh the DNA structure and you can't
uh continue to produce proteins and live
so some proteins have a half life of
seconds some minutes some hours but
they're not permanent structures so
every cell on our body is second to
Second constantly being rebuilt so the
genetic code is being read uh translated
in proteins produced on a constant basis
it's even coded in the protein how long
they'll live and their degradation rate
so it's a constant synthesis degrad
ation taking out the garbage and so
without the fundamental information
molecule there is no life that's a good
fundamental start cells you know have to
defy entropy they have to keep existing
by creating energy they take things from
the environment uh we have you know
hundreds of ways that different cells
make energy and the forms of life vary
from things that live at 135° Cen grade
down to Sub-Zero temperatures history of
biology is got defined in a human
Centric point of view so you know we
were the standard so nothing could live
out of 37° and we were the center of the
universe um we're not the center of
biology we may be the center of trying
to understand and interpret biology uh
but we're the minor species on the
planet um so key proteins and membrane
pump nutrients in pump waste molecules
out but it's a dynamic system that in my
View kind of spontaneously happens mhm
and we're trying to see right now if we
can get it to happen spontaneously when
we made the synthetic cell we made a Sy
we wrote the genetic code and we
developed a transplantation system where
we could put that chromosome in a
recipient cell that could read that code
and it read that code and then totally
transform that cell into what was
defined by that code so you change the
genetic code you convert one species
into another we're trying to now see if
we can do that in a cellfree system uh
to get spontaneous formation by having
all the components together so uh that's
long-winded way of saying we can't
Define life yet yeah I've had on
multiple people including uh Carl Zimmer
who from The New York Times and other
other venues I'm sure you've interacted
with I've had many many you know people
discussing the origin of Life Shadow
biospheres and everything but never
anyone who's claimed to create life and
it reminds me of this joke which you've
probably heard before but you know group
of scientists from jcvi you know go up
to heaven and they say God guess what
we've created life we've created life in
the in the lab and we can make a man out
of dirt and God says oh yeah well let
let me see you let me see you do that
that's pretty impressive and so the
scientist over there there they go
outside they scoop up some dirt and God
says hold on a second get your own dirt
you know meaning that you know you're
starting from from some base material
now obviously in the origin of Life
studies again there's almost no real
well-defined kind of uh uh path way or
or definition even of how the origin of
Life came to be we'll talk about my
favorite way which only explains how
life on Earth got started it's called
pan spermia we'll talk about that in a
minute uh because I'm very interested in
that and your thoughts on that and
aliens and all sorts of cool fun stuff
but the synthetic life it's it's you
know it's it's rare in a career that you
have one big hit I mean you've had hit
after hit after talk about what was the
Genesis of that were you looking was
there a sophomore slump fear that how do
I top you mapping there first of all you
weren't you didn't only map the human
genome you had M you made the first
complete genome map of what's the name
just
hopus that was in 1995 so 5 years almost
30 years ago it's coming up on the 30th
anniversary and that developed the tools
that made me know that we had a new way
to do the human genome that was new
mathematical algorithms for assembling
the generate code from the sequences
that we'd get if we wanted to do the if
you started from scratch and and you
know we took you away we put you on an
island you know with with with some
collaborators brilliant people computers
centrifuges PCR Etc how fast could you
do it today so how cheap could you do it
yeah it took us 10 years writing the
genetic code is very complex the
machines are slow we had to develop eror
they're not accurate so we had to
develop error correction uh methods you
can only make pieces so so large in size
and so we had to make multiple of those
and find ways to link them together as
you make larger pieces of DNA it gets
very brittle so you can't pipet it or do
normal things so we had to take new te
develop new techniques of putting it in
gels electronically and moving it around
in the gels so everything we did we had
to develop from scratch to be able to do
but the rate of synthesis was very
slow and the other problem was in the
final minimal cell about a quarter of
the genes are of unknown function
they're essential for life you take one
of them out the cell dies this isn't
junk DNA what they call junk the only
junk DNA is in my colleagues brains and
that's one of my pet peeves people come
up with these
overly
simplistic basically stupid ideas you
know that the part doesn't code for
proteins must be junk and so I offered
several of those people to surgically
remove their junk DNA and see how long
they live but there were there were no
volunteers but um the problem was we
tried to design life on first principles
based on what we thought we knew about
biology and it proved to be impossible
mhm so the reason it took so long and
part from the slow methods for synthesis
it was became trial and error we had to
add genes back then see how what of
those we could remove until we could get
a living cell so we'd add back a bunch
and then we'd get life and then we
worked out you know we can remove some
of those we had methods for knocking out
genes so we could tell which ones were
essential and which ones
weren't but so is basically a trial and
error process and I think it the biggest
finding and it's similar to what we
found with the ocean
microbiome is science reaches plateaus
of
knowledge and the Geniuses in the field
sort of trying to Define things as
though we know everything MH I mean I'm
sure it's happened in your field
multiple times so protein chemists
thought we knew all the protein folds we
knew all the protein family Ames it was
going to be hard to ever discover
anything new in the ocean stamp
collecting in the ocean you know they
thought there was only a handful of
different microbes and like proving junk
DNA is not junk instead of that being a
major finding you're you're just proving
some idiot's stupid statement calling it
junk DNA in the first place the
Challenger Expedition that we followed
was from the 1870s it was the first true
scientific expedition in the oceans was
sending a dredge down every 200 miles to
see what was on the bottom of the ocean
and again the brilliant Sayers at the
time said there couldn't possibly be any
life below 1,800
ft you know arbitr and so when they
discovered life at every depth including
they discovered the Mariana Trench and
life at the bottom smokers of everything
uh so it was
disproving
again an idiot notion you know I mean
there's there's Discovery Science we
show Discovery Science is Not Dead by
you can go out ask questions and make
more discoveries science is limited more
by this Dogma that gets set up of inan
ideas that if people really thought
about it you know they wouldn't come up
with them you know before we sequenced
the human genome people were arguing
that there were hundreds of thousands of
human genes
because there had to be a gene for each
trait and function I mean it just shows
how little was even fundamentally
understood about what a gene does what
protein does uh and that it wasn't
combinations of effects so the biggest
finding is we found 20,000 some OD genes
instead of hundreds of
thousands but it was only a surprise
because of the silly Notions there were
out there if they weren't there it would
have been oh yeah that sound makes sense
you know uh 20,000 comori is a huge
number yeah genetic Technologies
including gene therapy and synthetic
biology are surrounded by ethical social
and safety concerns however despite
being controversial they offer promising
opportunities to revolutionize medicine
improve personalize treatment and Tackle
various challenges of human life so it's
essential to stay up to dat with the
latest developments in this exciting
field for instance recently the FDA
approved the very first treatment to
used the gene editing tool known as
crisper which my wonderful guest on
today's episode Craig Venter talks about
they just approved it but the media
landscape surrounding these developments
is often fragmented making it hard to
find Reliable information and find a
balanced view which is personally why I
love ground news so much I even deleted
the iPhone news app that's default on my
phone and replaced it with ground news's
widget app and I also bought it for a
present for my older brother Kevin
ground news is an app and a website that
that gathers together all the world's
media into one place so readers can
compare coverage and see the full
picture of what's being reported
worldwide for every story you get a
quick visual breakdown of the news
outlets reporting it including their
political bias how factual the source is
which entity owns the source and which
countries are actually reporting and
covering the story for example let's
return to the fda's approval for the
first criser treatment right away you
can see that 162 news outlets have
reported Ed on the story of these 162
Outlets 23% lean left 11% lean right and
an overwhelming 66% come from the center
you can even see who owns the outlets
reporting on the story 63% are media
conglomerates ground news also makes it
easy to compare the headlines to see how
the bias might shape and influence the
framing of the story and affect our
understanding of one of my favorite
features of ground news is the blind
spot feed which allows you to see
stories that are underreported by either
side of the political Spectrum ground
news lets you get a deeper understanding
of the complexity and Nuance of
different issues by identifying media
narratives and their biases you can see
every side of the story and thus develop
a well-rounded worldview which is pretty
substantial in these turbulent times you
get access to newspapers and things that
are very hard to find go to ground.
newws drbryan to stay fully informed on
breaking news and compare media coverage
sign up or subscribe through my link for
30% off on limited access if you support
the mission and find it as essential as
I do to Scientific literacy when we
think about unsolved problems in in
physics there's the classic Notions of
of these Grand kind of prizes and so
forth that people will stake their whole
lives and careers on famous One Theory
of Everything can we find a single
equation that's maybe one inch long that
you could write that Einstein was unable
to do and of course going back to
schinger schinger came up with this
famous Paradox of the cat shinger cat
the superposition of living in dead
States and that was meant to to to sort
of reveal and and crystallize what he
thought of as a paradox in the
interpretations of quantum mechanics are
there similar problem in other words
like you know he would say things and
Einstein would retort back you know does
the moon exist when I don't look at it
and all sorts of God doesn't play dice
obviously is a famous One are there
interpretations of biology in other
words in in it's not clear that there
are that we know that there are only
four fundamental forces of physics the
strong and weak Force electromagnetic
force and of course gravity there could
be other forces sometimes they're called
fifth forces but we can't rule them out
and it's sort of an interpretative or
philosophical question are there
philosophies of biology in terms of
interpretations like could there be
genes that we don't know what they
express or what they produce because
we're looking at them through how humans
are currently you know could there be
something like some six sense that
humans have like polarization of light
are there genes that would Trace you
know the the sensitivity of polarization
in certain individuals uh that we just
don't know about cuz maybe we only
discovered polarized light relatively
recently it's a long one way of asking
are there issues in the interpretation
of genetics in the human genome well
totally even starting back as you said
with the origin of Life the assumption
that exists everywhere in biology is
that everything gets back to a common
origin that means if there was
panspermia there was only one event and
everything in in the biosphere came from
that one
event I've always just fundamentally
thought that was Bull uh it just doesn't
make sense and as you know the
fundamental chemicals of Life are found
universally they they're found on every
asteroid things are measured
on uh you know in my view is every place
you have the same fundamental components
we will fundamentally get life you know
my bumper sticker says life happens
and so I think there were thousands
maybe millions of
Origins there's competition for these
but to assume there was a singularity
event I think is just extremely naive
and what what is the most plausible in
terms of the extent versions of of not
just origin of life on Earth which which
is a huge problem to solve and and we
have Miller Yuri in our campus literally
a foundational experiment which is you
know not not currently as I understand
it as representative of the oxidizing
and reducing conditions of the early
atmosphere it was a cool experiment it's
a very cool experiment and that's super
fun to to talk about but that would only
and again forgive me when I used to do
biology experiments in high school Craig
you know we'd get a frog and we'd have
to dissect it and my frog would like not
even die like I was horrible in biology
so so I know almost nothing about it but
that would only solve life Origins on
Earth but what is a plausible in your
idea set of ideas for origin of Life in
the universe as a whole so in my second
book it's called life at the speed of
light and it's based on the one
invention I'm proud of it's It's a
biological teleporter it's called a
digital biological converter it was
based on the notion of that we can send
the genetic code through the internet
through electromagnetic waves any
combination of things regenerate that
code and regenerate life and the notion
was we can send a a DNA sequencer
smaller than this coffee cup to Mars or
other
places and instead of sending up A5
billion spaceship to fly back a sample
taken from the subsurface of Mars we can
send a sequencer sequence what's there
send the digital information back and we
can recreate the Martians easily here in
a laboratory using the tools of
synthetic bi ology so it's not the Star
Trek teleporter it's sending the digital
information for life but because that
codes for everything it can be
recapitulated my understanding is we
exchange about 100 kilogram of material
between Earth and Mars annually that's
right so various calculations you can't
take a shovel of uh Earth soil without
having Martian soil in it and so that
means when the oceans existed on Mars
and you know some evidence as they still
do on the serp surface that we will
either still find living organisms and
they'll very much resemble what we have
here that's a that's a a ter a meteorite
found uh in Argentina but behind you
somewhere else over there I've got a
sample of a lunar meteorite which
obviously hit the moon that's your gift
by the way came here came here so the
converse is also true we're changing
medium with with Mars so when life is
discovered in Mars It Will resemble life
uh that we discovered uh uh in the ocean
voyage and microbial life and viral life
will in my view be ubiquitous in the
universe now there's limits we can't go
right now above 135° Centigrade but we
wouldn't last too long at that
temperature personally and uh we have
microbes that live in very high doses of
radiation dakus
radiodurans uh the space station uh was
coded in part with that to see how long
it would survive and survived a long
time in fact one of the stories that I
tell that got the NASA director uh very
annoyed with
me uh I said the outside of the space
station is covered with
and it literally was because early on
they just pumped out all the human waste
uh outside and a lot of it stuck to the
outside of the space station now they
pack it into stainless steel containers
and launch it back into their Earth's
atmosphere so I tell people to be very
careful when they wish upon a shooting
star that maybe uh may be the wrong one
so life will live in space it'll live on
the surface of these things that will
live in nuclear reactors and geysers I
don't
Soh trying to extrapolate from human
biology would say well of course it
can't exist in other conditions the only
reason I'd like to live a long time
would be to see it proven that it is
ubiquitous and uh is everywhere we look
hey there fellow voyagers into the
impossible it is I your Fearless host
Professor Brian keading here with a
microscopically tiny request before
before we go back to exploring the
potential of biotechnology and its
ethical implications and that's to make
sure that you're all subscribed to the
podcast I did some research and number
crunching of my own and found out that
only 18% of you are actually subscribed
to the channel of all those that watch
it and to make matters even worse only
8% have notifications turned on you're
missing out on so much great amazing and
free content so make sure you like
subscribe and turn on notifications I
know you hear it from every single
YouTuber on Earth but to get the
greatest possible guest on this show I
really rely on that and will help me
help you so do it do it now before you
forget it just takes one little push now
back to the episode so the thought comes
to me you know when I read life at the
speed of light that you know that does
involve a much slower process than the
speed of light to transport the 3D
printer the sequencer Etc well you have
to get those there but the data can come
back at the speed of light so I guess
the obvious implication that I'm kind of
drawing from this is that well maybe
there were other civilizations and
species and so forth that created some
kind of sequencer which we call DNA and
that produced us what are your thoughts
about uh it seems that DNA which you're
you know at least as as as big an expert
as exists on the planet today that it
could be the most you know kind of basic
evidence for extraterrestrial not only
existence but intelligence am I like off
here I mean it's durable it's like I
I've heard of this long now have you
heard of the long now Foundation so
they're trying to build a 10,000 clock
BR and Kevin Kelly so 10,000 years is
child's compared to how long DNA has so
what are your thoughts about that as a
signature of ETI when my I was the first
human genome
sequenced and when that sequence was
finished to show people they should not
be afraid of their own
sequence uh it was put on the Internet
it's been you know broadcast so um my my
genome's been broadcast into space now
for 25 years so you know who knows
what's it may come back and you know a a
a troop of Craig venters may come back
and land here because it can be
recreated from the sequence um you know
but it's like human cloning you don't
get the same answer every time other
than in the uh the basic structural and
functional components we're still
plastic individuals in be modified but
and we're sending data into space
constantly uh people could be sending it
to us and we're we're not yet knowing
how to interpret those signals that are
coming in and the fact that it lasts so
long and you know has this durability
and resiliency is just is just so
striking and I don't think there's
anything that's create a ball in a lab
that has any you know that you can
create or that has been discovered that
has the durability of something like
that that's capable of being produced by
a mind by an intelligence source and
obviously that brings up Notions of of
all sorts of things like if you were to
construct the most likely evidence of
Life traversing the universe it would be
something that traverses at the speed of
light given the vast distances which
kind of brings me to my next question
which is about artificial life forms not
the kind that you synthesized but
necessarily artificial life artificial
intelligence and the question I have is
is really would it make sense to
teleport you know even these you know 3D
printers or even the code which still
has to rely on matter which cannot
travel at the speed of light if it has
mass versus pure information so um but
that's what DNA sequence is it's pure
information right and so that could be
sent anywhere and certainly short
distances it would be the fastest way to
get anything back from Mars
or Europa any place else it makes it
feasible to do that instead of waiting
for two a round trip of physical
material right it's the
fundamental chemical components we we
just talked about are basically
ubiquitous every place somebody looks so
having DNA form RNA form is extremely
likely and uh once it forms it can
accidentally code for something or it
can very specifically code for something
so in the first synthetic genome we
created a second code it was uh uh based
on Isaac's esf's uh uh rules of Robotics
we decided being the first one to make a
synthetic uh
organism uh that it should be
watermarked uh to clearly distinguish it
as a human-made organism deep fake
versus otherwise it could really confuse
everybody doing evolutionary studies for
example so we created a code you know
people have used asky code but that
creates problems so we created a unique
code that puts very frequent stop codons
in is for example we could write your
name and the genetic code with this code
but without the stop code on that could
lead to a new protein a toxin something
a very unintended consequences what what
is I'm sorry to interrupt but what would
be the likelihood of that it seems to me
if I go into my friends Tesla and I you
know I start to you know play around
with the code almost anything I enter
into it is going to destroy it's it's
less likely that's it's going to produce
you know something new and functional or
or just an oldfashioned Dodge you know
Wrangler Jeep R go in there with a
hammer and start playing around more
than likely unless you know do something
cosmetically you're going to make it
irreparable and possibly nonfunctional
so is that real I appreciate the ethical
concerns but is that really
probabilistically you know likely I
think there's a high probability of that
you know the uh all the microbes in the
environment are basically chemical
warfare with each other that's how we're
discovering so many new antibiotics uh
so they they create antibiotics to uh
deal with these chemicals they're
randomly evolved from just you know the
the biggest drivers of evolution in the
ocean are UV light and oxygen and that's
why there's so such a high rate of
mutagenesis when you doing doing this
experiment a 100 billion times
anything's possible yeah so that brings
me to you know some of the questions
that that naturally spring to mind I
mean the the the potential for for novel
uses of it incredible potential for you
know we just endured this you know
three-year pandemic right so what are
some of the concerns that you have
beyond beyond the you know it could do
something unintended what about the
intentional misuse of this technology so
it's one of the concerns that that we
had any virus any bacteria that's been
sequenced any pathogen we could readily
reproduce I think uh my friends in China
don't like me to say this but I think
aam's Razer says you have to prove that
Co wasn't a labade uh pathogen yeah um
you know could have come out of the
market but three people got sick there
they could have gone to the market so
you know they their alternate hypotheses
aren't impossible right they could have
brought it to the market could it could
have come from an
animal uh but uh NIH under Francis
Collin's Direction was funding gain of
function
research in this lab in China that we
had no control over I mean it's the
most unethical
thoughtless idea that I can imagine
sorry to interrupt but I have to just
get why was it done in China right
because it couldn't they couldn't
legally get it to be done here correct
they couldn't do gain of function
research it was forbid they could
definitely do it at CDC and the space
suit lab where we grow small pox and
everything else and
so doing it in a lab where you have no
control of the use or the outcome or the
processes the the fact that three people
got sick from the research there says
something wasn't being done right
because uh uh you know in the in the P4
facility at CDC they grow the worst
pathogens in the planet and we sequence
the smallpox genome as part of an
international treaty uh it was growing
up in the spacit lab and they would only
send us about a third of the genome at a
time to sequence so we would never have
the whole thing but uh uh it would be
easy to recreate just from The genome
sequence now so we do have to be
concerned with that um people created
the notion of Designing new
pathogens that's much more difficult in
part because we know so little about
biology I mean the the the fact that we
couldn't even design a living cell
because of all the
unknown uh functions out there essential
for life I mean nobody would have
predicted that not a single person in
biology would have predicted what we
found that's amazing and it just shows
we're missing at least a third to half
of all biological knowledge uh yet to be
discovered gain of function is changing
one or two genes to try and make things
worse the necessarily sorry to interrupt
again but but you know when I had Co I
only had I understand you had a horrible
experience with Co but I had a benign
relatively benign in fact I lost 10 I
dropped I always joke I dropped five
pounds from my double chin to my stomach
no I I lost weight you know I didn't
have smell and taste and you know it's
been more or less permanent yeah but
imagine and God forbid I'm not
suggesting oh it was really good because
Brian keing lost five pounds uh there's
more to come right uh but uh but the
question is Craig but you were
vaccinated as soon I was vaccinated yeah
didn't didn't prevent me somehow my wife
never got it and she's exposed to a
bunch of kids but the question I have
for you is there could be not just you
know there could be positive uses for
gain a function right not just negative
or weaponize it's important for leading
to
understanding but you got to do it under
the right conditions and the right
safety environment and places where you
have control I think there's reasons to
potentially do it but you want to do it
the right way with small pox which I get
very familiar with
not only sequenced the genome but once I
sequenced it it was supposed to be
destroyed and I convinced the government
that they should not destroy the stores
of small pox they're still in the uh in
the safe at the CDC it's this little
tiny oldfashioned save from the 1930s I
think great because I said it creates a
false sense of
expectation that we've rid the planet of
this pathogen when it could be reprod
produced very simply I I went and gave a
lecture to President Clinton his entire
cabinet on this this was even early days
before we really had all the synthesis
technology that we have now but because
the smallpox sequence was so closely
related to vaccinia which we used as a
vaccine against smallpox just during
site directed mut
Genesis uh a diligent team could convert
vaccinia into small po
now we could just synthesize it from
scratch these are not you know
ubiquitous methods there is a reason
that in the last 14 years no other lab
in the world has been able uh to make a
new life form like we have it's it's
expensive it's time consuming it's not
things government's fund um except maybe
in China but uh we also had an expert
team of 20 scientists including three
National Academy members and a Nobel
laurate and just some extraordinary
people working on all aspects of this so
teams like that don't get put together
very often in science uh especially
spontaneously and self-funded but there
are new tools coming uh we're working
with a company called Avery that is
doing DNA snthesis on computer chips
where they can make a different DNA
molecule on each pi pixel on the
computer chip and just by changing the
voltage on that pixel they can do deep
production change the chemistry and so
that could be a 10,000 fold increase in
our rate of doing synthesis which means
even though it's a trial and error
process because all the
unknowns instead of making one molecule
at a time and testing it which was hard
and time consuming we can maybe make a
thousand different
chromosomes and you your screen is for
life which one gives you a living cell
and so it will change the experimental
rate for doing things hopefully for the
betterment of mankind but you you every
time there's a breakthrough in
technology you have to worry about the
dark side so uh my organization created
a robot for
assembling uh DNA you know the notion
would have been from the digital
biological converter it just taken
sequence information and make a DNA or
protein molecule and it could do that
but we set it up so that the code could
not be changed you had to order the
prerequisite oligos uh from us so they'd
be in a tube I I designed 10 different
safety devices into it that if somebody
tried to modify it it would shut down
the machine nobody else is doing this
kind of stuff in science or even
thinking about it but we're we're trying
to think ahead on on it so the devices
we're creating for basic science didn't
turn into weapons manufacturers when I
look at your career and you already
mentioned Isaac azimoff who is you know
one of my big Inspirations obviously
this is part of the Arthur C Clark
Center for human imagination that I'm
the associate director of and I should
thank Eric Vey the director for
introducing me reintroducing me to you
after decade of not seeing each other
and and that is of course you know our
sir arthury Clark's visions and and uh
pronouncements and so forth that some of
which came to be science from the realm
of Science Fiction and I wonder you know
what seems like science fiction today to
you that could be a Grand Challenge akin
to mapping the genome to making
synthetic cells what what is the next
Frontier that seems again like science
fiction I mean we already agree that you
know making pathogens and so forth that
could be you know that that sort of
could happen now God forbid it does and
and and affects the planet but um but
tell me like What In Your Wildest Dreams
where do you go from here what's what is
a scientific science fiction fantasy for
for biology brief in before get there
the same tools that are used for making
potentially
pathogens are being used for creating
the countermeasures so biological
warfare wouldn't be a threat if we had a
repertoire of antivirals antibiotics
vaccines to deal with it and so we
created the first using the digital
biological inverter uh the first uh FDA
approv synthetic DNA vaccine and it was
made against a flu strain that was
discovered in China that looked very
pandemic
potential uh the Chinese sequenced it
and just posted it on the
internet we downloaded and made the
virus in in a week we were the only
source for the CDC and pharmer companies
of this virus because China wouldn't
export the biological molecule M but it
just shows you don't have to now you can
just send the information and
recapitulate it and so we did a test we
set up a device at novaris uh we sent
the sequence to them uh the device made
the molecule and they scaled that up for
vaccine production but everything that
happened with the covid
vaccines were really modeled after our
early success and uh uh you can make
large number of RNA molecules now and
and so our model with that you know
contributed to all of us getting
vaccinated against covid um but to
answer your question on on
the long distance Horizons the short
distance is going to be the potential
for totally new industrial
revolution of for example all the
microbes we discovered in the ocean they
make chemicals more complex than the
best chemists on the planet can
make and so taking those Gene Pathways
putting them in synthetic organisms will
be able to create whole new chemical
libraries that will change every type of
chemical therapy but also industrial
chemicals or building things making
things and the notion of this was
developed for ideas on making things on
Mars instead of sending everything up
there because it's very expensive to
build enough Rockets to carry everything
up there so if you can get microbes to
produce the building materials and the
chemicals and the food
substances uh that that would be the
future so I I think that's the near-term
future I proposed because you know while
I believe uh panspermia has happened and
is continually
happening we've already contaminated the
moon we've already contaminated
Mars you can't truly
sterilize things here on this planet in
a microbial world where there's viruses
and microbes in the air just everywhere
you are you can't eliminate them and so
we've sent microbes to Mars we've sent
uh you know people in poop to the Moon
we're pumping things out of the space
station so we're creating a of pans
spermia every astronaut that goes up to
the space station takes a totally
different repertoire of the
microbiome of millions of different
bacteria with it we've sequenced the
HEPA filters from the space station
they're loaded with so much diversity
and so much stuff it's it's just
stunning but I've argued that any
astronauts going to Future Planet
colonist ization we should sterilize
them first and give them a synthetic
microbiome so we're not creating a set
of new pathogens that would develop uh
in an environment so those are sort of
short-term
ideas Human Genome engineering is an
inevitable yeah we're not ready for it
now we understand 1 to 2% of the genome
at best when you say understand what do
you mean know what these genes code for
or why you have the traits that you have
why I have the traits that I
have you know we just had this recent
discussion here about uh imagination I
have a Fantasia so I don't see any
pictures at all in my mind I only think
in Concepts the person I was talking to
only sees in pictures uh and puts his
world together through pictures W and we
don't even know the simple basis of that
because uh NIH doesn't like to fund
behavioral uh studies uh that lead to
social changes on the human brain so
we're just not studying it you can't
understand bases of uh what's called
intelligence not that you know but
there's multiple different types it's
it's a spectrum of things so we're at a
still a very early stage of
understanding MH one method of survival
of our species
is going to be to engineer
humans to live in
environments that will be
inevitable because we're destroying
slowly the biosphere that we live in so
maybe it be humans that can tolerate
higher levels of CO2 or lower levels of
oxygen higher temperatures or higher
temperatures once we we don't even have
a
preliminary uh understanding of the
brain uh we think we do because we
understand more than we used to you know
so that seems like huge breakthroughs
but we basically understand nothing um
and we certainly don't understand the
genetic basis of how the brain is
hardwired so in inbred mice and ratch
the neurons are in the exact same
location in the BL brain plus or minus
just a few microns so all that's
completely under genetic control so we
start out being hardwired but we're also
hardwired to be plastic and
adaptable that may sound like a
contraindication but you know it's it's
part of the design antifragility to to
be adaptable and and our our brains are
plastic to a certain extent and can
change structure and function but we're
not really studying that
because we don't know what most of the
genes even do yet so uh we have to
increase our knowledge level before I
would ever be willing to start
engineering uh the human genome to
change humans interesting yeah kind of
it's reminiscent of you know the mapping
we have a periodic table on the wall
over here I don't think I can cap I
captured the lann those those those oh
the noble gases there there it is in the
corner over there you know most of these
were discovered by number you know in
the last you know hundred years or so
and of course many of them are important
for life but actually not as many as
You' think right I think the highest one
that's has some viability is like um uh
there's some amount of copper zinc
obviously is important but we I don't
think we need cadmium or technum Etc so
there's a lot of Wast very important
iron's very important but it's it comes
uh comes before copper as I mentioned in
zinc uh there's a little Arsenic and and
people have claimed they found arsenic
life that that went away pretty quickly
yeah I want to talk about an event I
think it happened 1997 you were um
considering leaving this company HDs and
going off on your own it it meant a
great sacrifice for you financially uh
in terms of uh stock options things you
had vested important um uh investors and
and relationships in the corporate uh
setting and you talk about you know
setting out to see to clear your mind
yeah it was not 97 it was actually uh
early
2000s i' sequence The genome I raised a
billion dollars cash for 3% of a company
with no Revenue I didn't get along this
is Sala yeah salera had a parent company
a pla that was sort of a holding
company uh a very volatile uh Cuban CEO
who only tolerated me because I was the
only one who could sequence the human
genome but and I I indicated to a board
member that once I was done with that
that I was considering going back to my
Institute cuz I wanted to keep doing
basic research he panicked they decided
it would you know if I left the stock
would crash so they got the brilliant
idea to fire me uh and the stock crashed
even faster um but you know went from
the the intensity of those years you got
an idea from the the book I was on the
front page of a newspaper almost daily
somewhere in the world the world was
watching every
move uh one thing I point
out there was thousands of reasons
perhaps why I should have failed okay
but I had the best team of scientist in
the world and they were all motivated to
make it work and make history you know I
was the Orchestra conductor you know
it's the team that actually did it Jee
Meers read the led the algorithm team
that wrote the whole new algorithm for a
simp 25 million sequences that uh nobody
else thought was even possible if it
hadn't worked it would have been the
biggest flame out in Science History
right I I would have been noted for the
fastest death in science uh from trying
to do something too big and too bold uh
but it worked but it was such intensity
it was a 24-hour day thing for two and a
half years building this then actually
sequencing the genome we didn't know the
White House Event was scheduled before
the computer stopped the calculation to
know whether we had a genome or not so
hey there it's me again are you enjoying
this incredible conversation with one of
the most brilliant thinkers alive Craig
bner then I know you'll love what I'm
about to offer you if you go to
bring.com list and join my mailing list
you will get the hottest news in the
cosmos from Consciousness in the brain
to life in the universe and that will
make you the star of any cocktail party
all this for free my weekly Monday magic
mailing lists always consider the
highlights from all around science and
especially from the into the impossible
podcast with links to transcripts and
giveaways and you may also win a real
piece of the early solar system maybe
the piece that brought life to Earth in
a pans spermic voyage across the cosmos
so do yourself a favor and go to Brian
king.com list and join now that's briank
king.com list now back to the episode
take us back to that because we're going
to get to The Voyage of the sorcerer one
I but talk about the race talk about you
Francis nah public private partnership
but rivalry and then winning it well
I've gotten lots of attention I've I've
got walls full of awards including the
national medal of science from Obama for
that work that I had to share with
Francis Collins but uh it's all right
so you know I approach
things pretty much as a basic science
scientist asking questions question so I
was trying to isolate the adrenaline
receptor work that started when I was a
student here at
UCSD and the standard in science then
before genomics was you'd spent 10 or 20
years trying to isolate a protein and
characterize it lots of Nobel prizes
have been given for single protein
discoveries and so when the first
discussions in the mid 80s came of the
idea to sequence the human genome which
everybody thought was
outrageous um I love the idea after
spending a decade trying to get one
protein the thought of just having all
the neurotransmitter receptors and
everything to do with cognition in one
step instead of waiting four centuries
to do it it was just a sexy idea to me
um I had the first automated DNA
sequencer because I was an intramural
NIH I had more money than God to do
whatever I wanted to do uh and you know
so I actually sequenced the first genes
in history with
Automation and so I had the only tools
to actually do what was being proposed
for the human genome I just got very
excited about the idea and Randomness is
a key theme in mathematics and cosmology
Serendipity it it it's also a key part
of what we did in genomics so shotgun
sequencing is you have to have a perfect
proon distribution of clones and then
you randomly select those and sequence
it and by doing that you can
recapitulate the entire genome can if
it's not truly random you can't do that
can I just ask when when you say
sequencing so I'm envisioning you know
this process you know running and and
and sequencing different you know Pairs
and and um even even individual yeah
individual base pairs Etc within the
gene right and then well the machine
spit out roughly a 500 Bas pair sequence
of that's what I was going to ask so
what was the fundamental atom of that so
okay go on it so we had 25 million
fragments roughly 500 base pairs long I
see okay continue and so that's the math
mathematical problem that had to be
solved putting that back together NH
refused to fund uh the grant that ham
and I submitted in 197 1995
this idea we had to sequence the first
genome yeah and even after we had it 90%
done you know we took money out of our
own bank account at The Institute to do
it it was over 90%
done I wrote a letter to Francis saying
look it's clearly going to
work uh you know I'm not trying to
embarrass
NIH if you fund it now you can still
share the credit for doing this MH and
he wrote back I have the letter it's I
think it reproduced in my book he stood
behind the study section who said this
is impossible it won't work a few months
later we announced the first genome in
history and so that that sort of created
you know a tension because I did it
outside the realm of this entire
Enterprise called the Human Genome
Project that was starting with a 5-year
project sequency coli and then yeast and
they were going to progress up to
nematode then
dropa and I kind of threw a monkey
wrench into that because eoli had barely
been started and and we did the first
one
independently and if you read the
science paper in 1995 I had to really
fight for this line to be in there but I
said that I believe this is the method
that will be used to sequence the human
genome right I was probably the only one
on the planet to who who believe that
idea but you know comes with maybe the a
Fantasia being able to think in
Concepts some things are just totally
obvious to me and and fortunately a
combination of great intuition and that
ability to put Concepts together the
only time I screw up in life is if I
ignore that intuition it's been right
100% of the time and and I you know just
refused to fund
these experiments to see it they had
their you was a public works project
they were Distributing billions to 100
campuses labs around the world and uh
you know LED Cindy brener to joke you
know why don't we have prisoners do this
you know if it's a forced Labor uh thing
to do but uh it made sense to solve it
mathematically and so we sort of gave up
and thought that uh I I was going to
have to sit on the sidelines
uh I got a call in fact I got several
calls I treated them I thought they were
junk calls and I ignored them uh of
offering me $300 million to start a
company to sequence the human genome wow
and it was applied biosystems the
company that was they were making a new
capillary sequencer that they thought
would fit with my method do these rely
on PCR and maybe you could explain okay
did you know Carrie when he was I knew
him well okay what was he like just a
side can we take a sidebar here he came
well first could you explain what PCR is
and why it wasn't relevant you know to
PCR was a method for you know it's like
a zerox machine for Mak copies of D it
was really a profound technique that
changed what people could do in the
laboratory he he's he's a genius but
really a crazy mofo torture torture well
he wild genius he's he's a fun guy I I
enjoy him and uh but uh he he he went
off you know with bizarre ideas HIV and
other things in the end but uh um we
use you know components of PCR to make
copies of the strands of DNA that were
going to be sequenced so yeah we had
rooms full of PCR machines that were
part of the process of getting enough
molecules of DNA that the automated
sequencing machines could read and those
were the capillary things that applied
was going to give you but uh so you know
they sent somebody out to see me and
said that they were sincere about the
$300 million and wanted me to start a
company and invited me out to Foster
City to look at their new machine which
was actually six breadboard devices
spread over six different
buildings and I looked at all of them
and I looked at the plary data and it
was totally clear to me that it was
going to work so we did some
calculations of how many machines it
would take to do this and it was funny
we uh made an order of magnitude uh
error too big and uh and so it looked
like it was going to take 30,000
machines and we were sort of saying well
this still might be doable Force and and
then we then we discovered there was a
10-fold error and I was oh uh in fact it
was 100 fold error because we only
needed 300 machines and even though that
was absurd all of a sudden by contrast
that seems so doable we thought okay
yeah 300 machines and $300 million we
can do this so I flew back to my
Institute I went to see my friend the
Nobel Laurette ham Smith who been
working with me for 20 years and I said
look I looked at the machine I I'm
certain it's going to work if we get 300
of these machines and scale everything
up I think we have a shot and they're
giving us the resources to do it he goes
I don't think it will work but I'm I'm
going with
you that's and that was that's sort of
how the whole team
built of i as soon as I announced it we
got a thousand applicants of the best
scientists in the world the best
mathematician physicist we had to build
the third largest civilian computer in
the world a whopping one and a half Tera
flops which cost it roughly a hundred
million doll to build and now it's a few
thousand computer it's kind kind of gpus
cool how how how fast things change but
uh it worked because of the
dedicated incredible team that I built
it I don't think a te team's been built
like it before after Ham's complaint
afterwards was uh it was such a unique
experience uh we did it too quickly
because we sequenced The genome in 9
months and then you know just gave the
illusion that it was a simple eror than
it was things exploded but so the
intensity of this uh was so much when I
was fired from there it was just like
going into a sensory deprivation
tank and so I decided I had to do some
recouping before deciding what I was
going to do next so I got on my boat and
uh sailed down and lived in torola for
several months working on my boat and
thinking of uh ideas of what I was going
to do uh came back and and started uh
three new not for-profit institutes to
one to do the environmental work uh one
to do synthetic biology and one to uh
build off the ideas off the human genome
and but uh it it took that you know
rebuilding period just you know after
anything that intense you know when
you're in the Press every day hounded
every day
uh the whole it was you know it was a
very unique experience during the
negotiation uh with the White House when
I agreed to do that my colleagues hated
me for it um they were jealous or no no
no uh my colleagues at at at salero
because we were so far ahead oh right
why give up the share the glory and
scientists Like Richard larner uh
locally I had a dinner with him
I told him what I was going to do he he
got viscerally angry with me
so people wanted me to embarrass NIH and
the government for all the horrible
things that they've done right well
they've certainly done but but tell me
do you regret it if you could go back
would you have done that no because it's
the notion was you know trying to be
publicly minded with this I mean
emotionally would that have felt great
to to embarrass the hell out of them
that you know uh we we did it with uh
100 million instead of five billion and
we did it in nine months my ideas got
proven right and the team got proven
right and uh I knew that if I didn't
make the
compromise to do the announcement at the
White House that the following year or
two when they eventually finished they
would do that and we would be totally
left out of it right it's like they say
the third guy makes the money from the
house you know the first guy loses all
the money the second guy still loses
money the third guy sells it a bill so
so it was a negotiated you know truce
but it was really based on what sler was
doing and I would get calls every day
you know as the computer run stopped yet
and the you know cuz they were having to
schedule all these dignitaries was on
you know live International TV and we
didn't have a genome yet sea change yeah
I remember that very well I was at
Stanford but but it got it got down to a
game of chicken in the end um because I
had to share my speech with the White
House um because it was going to be live
television from the White House um
you're not GNA and they Tony Blair was
going to be part of it because England
was such a big part of the genome effort
and they sent me Tony Blair's speech and
it was just totally insulting totally
one-sided praising the public effort and
attacking this company that you know
intervened right business and I called
the White House science advisor and said
unless Tony Blair changes his speech I'm
not
coming wow this was the night before the
White House Event he said you're asking
us to change a foreign head of state
speech we can't do that and I said well
I know you can and you will uh if you
want me to show up they did uh he called
me at 1:00 in the morning and he goes I
can't send it to you but I guarantee
that you will be very happy uh with the
changes that he's made in fact I was he
change at
180° so that all the scientists in
England were totally off with Tony Blair
CU he was being so nice to me but uh you
know but these games you know I just
shows the intensity of all this stuff
and and in the book you talk about
Francis and there there's a line that
really resonated shockingly so you said
something to the effect that he was more
interested in the credit than the
process or the money or or anything and
that that really it's kind of Haunting
you know to to think that there are
people doing the science and
it is truly you know about them and
about their egos and about their
reputations and and you know you don't
have to comment on if you don't want it
but you did write it in the book but as
you know it's that's the history of
science there there's been some of the
bigest battles even early on here at
UCSD uh with some of the big areas you
can't work at these levels without
having a strong ego yeah and so it's a
question what's what's the driving force
I mean you want your ideas to be
right
um but we were still trying to do it in
a publicly minded fashion you know we're
taking private money we gave the G
genome away for free uh uh to
scientists uh I had a chance to
embarrass the the government my view is
they were embarrassing themselves so we
agreed to share the credit even even
though it
wasn't so different scientists are
totally motivated
by different things were given
disproportionate attention Fame then you
can probably get in most other areas
other than being a rock singer or
something but when it combines with
power I mean I had on Jay bachara from
Stanford who's a good friend of mine
dear dear person of course you know in
late you know 2020 there was articles
circulating around that there were you
know Fringe epidemiologists including
him and a no about at St I think Lan uh
at Stanford who joined in and we have to
um you know basically censor them or
mock them humiliate them so that they
don't get attention and one of the ways
was to have you op-eds in the in the
Washington Post and I found that really
despicable and it's not surprising when
I reread your book your life decoded
that was you know kind of a character
trait that I have to confess wasn't that
unfamiliar from the way he is 25 years
later yeah you can do good science and
make good
contributions but your ideas as an
individual can be really effed up
and my quote friend Watson it has proven
that James Watson by and he's now been
censored by his own institution and
fired you know because uh I I think he
did make important contributions not
necessarily the role and the model of of
DNA structure but but you know he helped
build called Spring Harbor and raise
money and and do things for it you know
he he has contributed positively to
science but he he's one of the biggest
racist and sexists on the planet and
that does a disservice of almost
counteracting any good that he might
have done um and he's not the first one
there's uh you know uh other Nobel
laurates that are really gone off on on
sh shley you know was sort of the
predecessor there and just because
people are bright in a certain area
doesn't mean they have the right ethics
and morals and you know when I announced
I was going to sequence the human genome
uh Watson called me
Hitler uh and you know that I was taking
over things but he seemed directly
threatened yes it's very scary yeah well
because uh he was constantly Afraid from
the science they did in the discoveries
that it would shut down Congress funding
their program if it was going to be done
faster and cheaper by
industry and instead it was a very
bizarre situation and you know we had
the US government and other governments
competing against a startup biotech
company in the United States I I guess
the only one who would understand that
at all is Elon and he's done pretty good
with with his competition against NASA
but in part from learning from some of
the things we did China funds its uh
biotech companies it supports them yeah
uh only in America would we have the
government competing with a startup
biotech Company by outs spending it 50
fold or suppressing contracts yeah so it
it's it's bizarre stuff but I guess
that's that's the diversity of of our
system the cool thing is I could have an
idea like I had it obviously stimulated
others uh to give me the resources you
know they didn't do it in a selfless
fashion they wanted to sell their
machines and they made billions selling
the machines because I made them work uh
but that's okay that that's capitalism
at work the net effect was I got to do
first class science for the public
benefit uh and moved it along 10 years
faster yeah let's get to some fun uh
Science question questions and actually
some voyages as you said earlier The
Voyage of this Voyage of the Challenger
back in the 1800s obviously we we
haven't mentioned the probably the most
famous biological Voyage until the
sorcerer 2 which is the beagle in
biology um well the Beagle the Beagle
was a survey void that had a naturalist
on board that just went along to make
observations along the way so it wasn't
actually a scientific Expedition right
but it's definitely the most famous uh V
and the observations that that Darwin
made are fundamental was that when you
get life in isolated environment it it
there's evolution of unique genetic
characteristics ass Associated because
it's an isolated environment MH we see
that today in human populations where
there's been inbreeding uh for example
Saudi Arabia was based on 12 ban tribes
all first cousin marriages within the
tribes not even between them uh they
have some of the highest rates of
genetic diseases in the world second
type 2 diabetes only to the Puma
Indians why because type 2 diabetes was
a survival Advantage for the ban
existence of feast and famine right once
they switch to a steady Society diet it
becomes a disease right uh but it's
locked in and with in breeding uh even
worse so uh Darwin's work totally
predicted that in advance and what we're
using today but I had the pleasure of
following his exact
steps only I had a new lens I call it
the lens of
genomics we could see things by looking
at the genetic code after it was
sequenced that he couldn't see even if
he had good
microscopes uh so we discovered uh
10,000 times the life forms that he
discovered but they were the bases of
all the life forms he discovered
existing but that's you know that's what
happens it happens to your field you you
get a a new telescope that can see
further new
instruments all of a sudden the lens of
genomics
changed the entire world microbiology
was based on on what you could see
through a
microscope or what you could get to grow
on an augur plate mhm and if it would
grow on auger plate it was deemed not to
exist and that's why that's what started
this Expedition they were discovering
microbes in the ocean and numbering them
one at a time so SAR 11 was the 11th
microbe discovered in the saraso and
there was this paper by a physicist in
pnas on uh that I read when I was on
sorcerer one
recuperating of how little diversity
there was of life in the ocean and as a
lifelong sailor swimmer Surfer diver
this just didn't make any sense to me at
all
because uh half the oxygen we breathe
comes from the ocean the diversity of
all the food does and that's where I got
the idea just to use the same method we
use for the human genome to try shotgun
sequence in the ocean mhm and discovered
just from the very first experiment
where they had 11
organisms we discovered 2,000 in just
the first sequencing experiment and 1.4
million new genes wow so we followed the
Challenger we took samples every 200
miles around the globe over 65,000 miles
covering most oceans and
seas and uh uh even early on Discover
covered more new microbes than there are
stars in the universe which made it
easier to recruit physicists and
mathematicians because all of a sudden
they said biology was a bigger problem
that's exactly right yeah makes
cosmology seem easy so that Voyage began
in what year did you start the first
voyage well the early experiment started
in
2003 uh and then really got going a few
years later where we did a full
circumnavigation but like everything
science you know it wasn't as easy as
just going out like Darwin did and
taking samples and making observations
um Darwin didn't have Peta or he he
would have been sued multiple times for
the experiments you know when he
discovered the iguanas he couldn't
believe that they could breathe
underwater so he tie stones to them and
throw them in the water and see if
they'd survive and uh you don't do that
with your graduate
students well you can do it with
graduate students that's okay but um so
we had to get permits we had to work
through the state department with every
country where we wanted a sample in
their 100 mile
border uh and encountered numerous
problems we got arrested twice uh we got
threatened with Sinking by the French
and the
British uh we got bordered by a SWAT
team in Australia uh just asking basic
science questions in a world that's
fearful of science is not always easy no
it is not um so is there going to be a
the next Voyage of a sorcerer two or
maybe even a sorcerer three what do we
have to look forward to on the oceans uh
well the good thing is you know when
it's a a simple idea and most good ideas
and science are pretty simple ideas we
showed that we could just take a sample
from the
environment isolate the microorganisms
for sea water it's simple we just had of
a series of milore filters that collect
things at a very tiny level so we
collect the viruses on one filter the
microbes on the other the diatoms on
another we just put the filters in the
freezer until we could get to a port
send the back to the Venture Institute
where we shotgun sequenced everything on
the filter it's an idea now there's been
hundreds of many and major
voyages uh copying this um anybody
listening any kid can take a a little
vial go out to the nearest stream Lake
uh River ocean Estuary take a sample
isolate the microbes sequence them and
make more discoveries uh than were made
in the 1900s of new organisms cuz we
have that much diversity out there
remaining to be discovered is there any
way that they can actually you submit
them for analysis unless they well uh
people have been putting more more of
these the public databases and in fact
it's one of the problems we're trying to
solve with the synthetic cell most of
the genes discovered by us and others
are of unknown function so we have now
developed this catalog of biology on the
planet where without knowing the
function of the majority of things that
have been discovered so we uh were in
the infancy of science not in a mature
stage well uh Craig this has been
phenomenal and there's much more to come
uh but what I love to do now is um is in
the beginning part of the conversation I
know you have a limited time here I
don't want to miss my audience questions
so what we're going to do is we're going
to end the main episode episode of the
channel the conversation with with Craig
and then in order to see part two or the
question and answer period as well as to
hear Craig's answers to my final four
existential questions on the meaning of
life advice to his former self the most
magical technology ever invented by man
and what what what he expects to uh give
uh as as a future sort of Legacy for the
planet you'll have to subscribe to my
mailing list at bring.com
list and if you show me this little
meteor right there you will actually get
a chunk of this rock and we have some
talks about panspermia questions about
panspermia in the bonus episode so to
get the bonus episode go to bring.com
list I will send it out to you as soon
as it's ready and you may even win a
chunk of Space Rock in fact you're
guaranteed to win a chunk of Space Rock
what I do Craig is anyone with a.edu
email address who uh joins my mailing
list gets a guaranteed fragment of this
4.5 billion year old piece of space
Schmutz sent to them along with its
assay and we'll even put on some of
Craig's DNA I'm going to have him
slobber over some of the meteorit so
tune in uh to uh to part two you'll get
the link uh when you join the mailing
list and for now Craig thank you so much
for being a guest on the into the
impossible podcast